les premiers visiteurs se pressent dès 9
heures ce matin les couloirs du château
de chambord désert depuis six mois
retrouvent leur public
pour l'occasion certains touristes sont
venus de région parisienne on est mieux
comme ça par hasard et puis on savait
que le 19 verture était prévu donc en
est arrivé donc c'est très bien c'est
parfait ça fait du bien de revoir un
petit peu d espaces qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude depuis l'habitude de visiter
on n'est pas nombreux on peut prendre le
temps et on voit tout le monde et est
content de pouvoir que boucher un petit
peu et de pouvoir revenir à des sorties
comme ça quoi la tante de la réouverture
et est immense pour les visiteurs mais
aussi pour les employés
ces dernières semaines ils se sont
affairés pour que tout soit parfait pour
le grand jour on est rassuré de réouvrir
on est rassuré de voir les visiteurs
retrouver le chemin de chambord on a
besoin nos visiteurs pour faire vivre le
château
et puis notre métier est un métier
d'accueil donc quand on a pas de public
bien on est un petit peu comme des
musiciens qui ne n'aurais pas de nini
d'orchestre need public pour jouer à
l'occasion de la réouverture le château
propose la première représentation d'un
spectacle équestre très attendu devant
le château les cavaliers raconte la vie
de françois 1er devant les yeux ébahis
des spectateurs
c'était super d'être est très bons
cavaliers un super spectacle très
amusant et très apprécié au deuxième
étage du château une exposition d'art
contemporain investit les appartements
classique pour l'artiste la pandémie a
été une source d'inspiration la
catastrophe planétaire est tombé et donc
quelque part se confirme on a poussé
encore plus loin plus loin la volonté de
la crête de dépassement de la création à
chambord les sourires se devine derrière
les masques et la vie reprend partout
dans le château